dude there's this guy uh people are
gonna laugh at me because i don't know
or if you know who this is uh is it
andrew lloyd webber i forget who i
forget the guy's name is that the fan of
the opera guy yes
so you get school of rock phantom of the
opera and evita which are all big hits
that i've heard of and then i've never
heard of jesus christ superstar but yeah
that's apparently like done in the 70s
yeah he uh he's a billionaire
yeah so i looked up so when i thought of
that play model i was like is the play
is the play business a good business it
could be and i think it can be so the
the top
the top ip
definitely accrues like a ton of
value like i said if you you can go look
at like lion king is grossed like two
point something billion dollars uh
that's the number one stage play number
two hamilton is like getting up there
it's like it's like number two or three
now but it's like very new so it'll
it'll surpass lion king if it just keeps
going um there's like fan of the opera
there's mamma mia there's like so you
take the top ten and they're all doing
like hundreds of millions in gross sales
okay now you don't get to keep the gross
sales but i think you
could do this in a way that works so
like the guy who created hamilton lynn
manuel whatever his name is yeah but did
the uh did the author get paid too on
that one
uh so he gets so this guy lynn who's the
creator of it he uh has like a seven
percent royalty or something like that
wow so he's made like tens of millions
of dollars off of the the profits they
actually crowdfunded the thing uh so
what they did i don't have the full
story in front of me because i'm just
trying to say this off top my head from
a memory but
i think what they did was to raise the
money to create the thing they had like
a bunch of patrons basically chip in
money and they all get to keep a profit
share after a certain amount of money
had been recouped and so that investment
has been paid over like 10 times so if
again if i was hustling i'd be like hmm
there's web3 going on interesting a
lot of people flush with cash buying
into okay cool digital tickets nfts
okay what can i do with this and i would
basically
raise 10 million dollars
through an nft pre-sale
of the show
and uh in different tiers like you know
some of the tickets have backstage
passes attached to them some of them
don't whatever it's interesting and i
would i would just let people buy buy
this i'd raise 10 million dollars i'd
use the 10 million dollars to go into a
bunker to create whatever the health
hamilton black people is and then i
would hamilton brown people for indians
oh yeah sorry not black people brown
people so then i would take that show on
the road and i would just try to i would
be like yeah i know it's hard but like
being a successful stand-up comedian was
also like a 0.1 percent success rate or
whatever
um you know to get to where he's at so
like yeah you want to get to the point
one percent success rate but this time
with a superior business model that um
doesn't require your face on stage
saying the jokes
yeah i think that's sick i think that's
a that's a great idea i think that's
actually that's wonderful i think and
that could be incredibly creative
creatively fulfilling
i wish i had said it on the spot it's
like one of those when you're in an
argument and then like later you're
interested in that oh i should have
said that that's what happened to me but
luckily we were still hanging out at
that moment so i was able to tell them
you know then ah this is a cool idea i
think in the next couple episodes what
i'm going to do is i'm actually going to
bring in i'm going to do some research
on the broadway business or like
theater i guess what do you call it
theater yeah um it's actually an
interesting idea i was always curious
because american idiot basically they
did this so billy joe armstrong wrote
green day wrote american idiot the album
the song they turned it into a uh a rock
musical right you didn't have to be
there they didn't have to be there you
know exactly and
they got paid a lot from it book of
mormon let me see how much book of
mormon has made
of mormon
yeah
500 million dollars has been the gross
ticket sales of book of mormon and then
if you did something like a hamilton or
like a lion king or whatever you could
take that same ip those characters you
have merch you have like other
that ip is your key is you got to own
the ip
and um you know so so i think you know
when that when book of mormon launched
it says it was bringing bringing in 19
million per month so like i don't know
what south park generated lifetime but
like i bet it's kind of like on par with
that uh or you know i guess south park's
probably a bigger success um
yeah
oh wow south park
okay just in 20 i didn't know this
happened actually it looks like a couple
months ago the south park creators
signed a 900 million dollar deal for
more episodes for for uh six years uh
with viacom cbs that's insane i didn't
know that that's actually amazing
that's amazing right now is the best
time ever to be a like a production
company or an ip holder and we said this
a long time ago remember i said someone
needs to there's all these platforms now
you got
at the time it was netflix amazon prime
and then i said disney plus was gonna
come out it hadn't come out yet um and
then there was like you know there's
hulu there's all these different
platforms apple tv plus came out um
they all want original content they're
all hungry for content and they are
betting billions of dollars uh budgeting
every single year to buy content i think
netflix or amazon or something like
they're paying like six billion dollars
per year for content uh for new content
production and so it is the best time
ever to be a seller of content at the
time we had said somebody should create
yc for content basically the way that y
combinator helped produce software
startups and i just said hey two
engineers okay you're 21 years old you
graduated from stanford all right come
here this is essentially like a business
school but you're going to create a
little business and you know maybe you
can sell to facebook or google or you'll
end up becoming the next airbnb you'll
go public
i think the same thing with the content
where you come in as two kind of like
creatives you have a pitch for an idea
of a show you want to create
you have three months to basically
create the sizzle reel or the pilot or
whatever and then there's a demo day
with a bunch of buyers from all the big
streaming platforms and they just buy
options on your and um i just think
that's a beautiful i still think that's
a great business idea and it's only been
proven when
south park signs a 900 million deal with
with cbs uh shonda rhimes i think signed
a couple hundred million dollar deal
with netflix to produce six shows um
reese witherspoon sold her production
company which didn't even have that like
for like a billion for like a billion
dollars um like this is you know this is
tech startup money that's being sold for
for tv content which is amazing so you
know that's a that's way more fun than
building software
way more way cooler um way cooler than
that and i think today hussmannaj also
announced his production he created a
production company today he announced it
like 100 things called 186k productions
or something like that which is smart
again like once you see reese
witherspoon and other people's
production companies selling and we had
rob deerdeck on i think he said he sold
his production company for 200 something
million he said that he i think he said
he's walking away with 100 him
personally
yeah so like i think you know at least
let's say at least 100 million probably
closer to 200 million he sold his
production company which basically just
produced shows for mtv that's a great
business to be in and i think it's only
going to get better for like this kind
of five year period